Once Upon a Time uTorrent was basically
synonymous with torrent it was the go-to
place to download movies music games or
something a bit more mature and fun fact
it was actually owned by Spotify in the
early days who bought the company to
learn about their peer-to-peer
distribution system Spotify would end up
selling you torrent as they wanted to
dissociate from the world of piracy but
this didn't stop you Toren from
exploding in popularity anyway till just
3 years ago they held nearly 70% market
share within the torrenting world with
second place coming in at just a tenth
of the market share at 6.6% the funny
part is that second place bit torrent is
actually the creator of bit torrent but
they never held a candle against the
popularity of a uTorrent which at their
Peak translated to over 1 150 million
users but while uTorrent still controls
a dominating share of the market the
overall Pie has not just shrunk but it
has become become a sliver take Google
trends for example the search interest
around UT torrent has basically been
non-existent for the past 7 years with
current interest standing at just 3% of
their former Peak uTorrent has very much
been trying to fight this trend for
instance they launched a web version of
utorent a couple of years ago and while
that did reach a million daily active
users it's nothing in comparison to
their Glory Days as such uTorrent is
very much feeling the pain and at this
point it seems like they're just
fighting for survival they've stuffed an
ads into their UI and introduced pay
teers in hopes of keeping the effort
worthwhile but with interest in U
torrent continuing to dwindle this seems
like an increasingly uphill battle
that's why when uTorrent temporarily
went down in early 2023 many speculated
if that was the end of uTorrent
altogether fortunately for UT torrent
and its remaining users this wasn't the
case but it did give a glimpse in to the
inevitable future but what happened how
did everyone forget about a once
ubiquitous service with over a 100
million users well join me as we take a
look back at the Monumental rise and
fall of the king of
torrent you torent very much popularized
the idea of downloading files in a
decentralized manner and companies are
currently popularizing the idea of
raising money in a decentralized manner
with the help of bonds if you're not
familiar with bonds it's essentially a
way for governments and companies to
raise money from the general public as
well as other companies and financial
institutions these companies and
governments will then turn around and
use this money to fund expansion efforts
research and development and growth and
in return for helping them out they'll
pay you back with interest of currently
4 to 7% investors like Warren Buffett
are currently buying bonds hand over
fist and locking in historically High
interest rates for the long term if
you'd like to do the same thing with the
safety of $500,000 in sipc insurance and
$2.5 million in FDIC Insurance please
consider checking out our bond investing
app Silo in the description below but
anyway getting back to UT torrent The
Story of utorren takes us back to the
early 2000s to a Swedish programmer
named Ludwig stus Ludwig never had any
aspirations of creating something
massive or being in the spotlight he was
just a programmer who liked solving
issues that he came across on a
day-to-day basis and uTorrent was one of
these creations you see Ludwig was
involved within the torrenting space in
the early 2000s and he couldn't stand
that most bit torren came along with a
bunch of bloat wear and were resource
Hogs so in 2004 he started working on a
no FR spit torrent in his free time this
was very much an on andof thing in fact
after working on it for just 1 month
Ludwig would lose interest and sideline
the project for nearly a year but he did
eventually come back to it in September
of 2005 with a new Vigor in fact he
would finish off the program in just 3
days and launch utorent on September
18th 2005 speaking of the Dame if you
look closely at the logo you'll see that
the first letter isn't exactly a u when
I was a kid I always thought that this
was just a stylized curs of you but this
is actually a Greek letter called Mew in
the Computing World Mew usually refers
to micro so you could pronounce uTorrent
as MW torrent or microt torrent and this
is actually the case in many countries
if this is true in your country comment
down below where you're from but for
most users including Ludwig himself the
Mew looked like a u and thus it became
known as UT torrent within just a few
months of launch hundreds of thousands
of people would end up downloading their
client and Ludwig would continue adding
add new features for example uTorrent
would become one of the first clients to
implement DHT support and bit torrent
encryption but while these were nice
additions the main factor that sold
uTorrent was its lightweight Design This
didn't just catch the eye of pirates
though it also caught the eye of Daniel
eek the future CEO of Spotify back in
2005 though Daniel was just another
Swedish programmer who is fascinated by
the inner workings of utorent and
especially Ludwig you see it Daniel had
already begun working on Spotify and
they were figuring out the hard way that
pursuing a server client model for
streaming music would be extraordinarily
expensive so instead they wanted to
leverage a lightweight peer-to-peer
model and who better to help them than
Ludwick and with that Spotify would
purchase you torrent for an undisclosed
amount which was likely less than a
million dollar this means that Spotify
CEO was technically also you torn CEO at
one point in time but this didn't last
all that long as Spotify CTO put it we
bought you torrent but what we really
wanted was Ludwig as such as soon as
they were able to convince Ludwig to
stick around at Spotify they would turn
around and sell UT torrent to bit
torrent behind closed doors it wasn't
until years later that it would be
revealed that the sellers were actually
Spotify this was basically the end of
ludwick's involvement with UT torant and
looking back this was a great decision
as Ludwig would end up with a $100
million when spot I ipoed but while
Ludwig had already moved on utorent was
just getting
started while Ludwig was no longer
involved the truth was that UT torrent
had been turned over to someone even
more capable braah Cohen if you're not
familiar with Braum he's the father of
torrenting as he created the world's
first peer-to-peer bit torrent and he
aply named the program bit torrent but
while bit torrent was the OG braah could
see that uTorrent was op it was faster
more efficient and had a better UI but
most importantly it was rapidly growing
in popularity so armed with VC funding
Braum would take the plunge with
uTorrent but not everyone was happy you
see Braum didn't exactly create Torrance
with piracy in mind obviously he knew
that it would happen but his main goal
with Torrance wasn't to enable piracy it
was to make Torrance a mainstream way to
download pretty much anything and if he
wanted to make that happen it was
important that Braum was on the right
side of the law so in late 2005 he would
go ahead and strike a deal with the mpa
or the emotion pictures Association of
America this deal entailed that Braum
would remove all copyrighted material
from the official bit torrent search
engine this move turned a lot of the
torrenting community against Braum as
much of the tor tortin Community was
also Pro piracy moreover much of the
tortin community was in favor of a
decentralized network by purchasing UT
torrent though Braum was basically
monopolizing the torrent space so the
core torrented Community wasn't happy
with any of this but as far as the
general public was concerned well they
really didn't care or even know about
any of this as far as they were
concerned utorent was by far the best
bit torrent client and the problem was
simply making it more St able and
accessible also about bra taking down
copyrighted Torrance well this simply
made way for the Pirate Bay kickass
Torrance and a slew of other search
engines for torrent leading us into the
Glory Days of uTorrent by 2008 uTorrent
boasted over 25 million active users and
it was basically synonymous with torrent
but there was one major problem money
all of this was funded using investor
Capital meaning that sooner or later
investor ERS would want to see a return
this was very much a tricky line to walk
as doing anything over the top would
simply push away users and make way for
a new bit torrent so the company started
off simple they would start bundling in
optional toolbars into their
installations they would also add in a
Google Power Toren search these actually
brought in a decent amount of Revenue an
estimated $15 to $20 million per year
but with a 125 million users to support
and the 2008 financial recession it's
simply wasn't enough in fact bit torrent
would be forced to do layoffs and close
parts of their business but despite the
losses bit torrent was able to scrape by
mostly thanks to just how stupidly
popular utorent was investors Wen going
to just let a platform with over a 100
million active users go under just
because of a funding issue so they
helped keep Boran to float but see this
only works as long as U torrent is
growing at an unprecedented rate which
we know wouldn't last forever
the truth is that much of you torrent
Fall From Grace wasn't even their fault
the reality is that interest in torren
has simply Fallen substantially over the
past decade thanks to more affordable
legal options entering the market
ironically one of these options is of
course Spotify which has largely made
music piracy a thing of the past so by
helping Spotify succeed Ludwig actually
ended up killing his original invention
which is quite poetic actually but
Spotify was just one factor this same
Trend occurred in basically every
copyrighted industry you no longer had
to pay $40 to $60 per month just to
watch TV shows and movies with a bunch
of ads instead you could just pay $10
per month to Netflix and get access to a
far larger Library whenever you want the
same thing could be said about gaming as
well many of the most popular games of
the 2010s whether it's Clash of Clans or
fortnite were completely free to play
these games made their money based on
in-game purchases making it completely
useless to Pirate their games and as for
games that were still paid well a lot of
these were dependent on online
functionality which you couldn't really
get if you pirate and as for software
well most software just became free to
use as they learned to monetize our use
of them as opposed to our purchase of
them just as all of this was starting to
unfold some of the biggest piracy sites
would be taken down this included mega
upload in 20 2012 and the Pirate Bay in
2014 of course Replacements would pop up
to take their place but these never
reach the same skill because people
simply didn't feel the need for these
Services I mean just take a look at this
graph showcasing the interest around
downloading free movies and as piracy
began to lose team it was only natural
that utorent followed suit making them
more and more desperate first they would
add ads in late 2012 then they would add
a pro tier for $20 per year which kind
of nerfed the free tier these changes
definitely made the free version of
utorren less appealing but these changes
were also understandable at the end of
the day utorent was a business that
needed to make money but a change that
the community would not tolerate however
was deception in early 2015 utorent
would begin secretly installing a
cryptocurrency minor onto users
computers in order to mine Litecoin and
generate some more Revenue Not only was
this blow where but it was rather Shady
given that uTorrent was very much trying
to do it under the radar and with that
uTorrent had officially been around long
enough to see themselves become the
villain and this pretty much sealed the
Fate for Utorrent the core torrented
Community would move on to other
services like Cubit torrent while the
general public would ditch torrenting
alt together leading us into UT torr's
current situation for years now bit
torrent has been shutting down service
after service after service so uTorrent
may very well be on the chopping block
next the financials of uTorrent aren't
public so it's difficult to judge the
financial viability of you torrent maybe
UT torrent is Break Even or even
slightly making a profit it's not clear
but what is clear is that the Glory Days
of UT torrent are long behind us and all
we have left is a shell of their former
selves someone else that went through a
similar journey is the Pirate Bay if
you'd like to hear about their story
check out this video but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one